This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We begin today with a tale of a man known as a miser. A man so unmoved by the plight of others, that he has become synonymous with greed and selfishness. His name was Ebeneza Scrooge. Mr. Scrooge, I presume, indeed you do, sir. Scrooge, of course, was a character and child's dickens as famous story, a Christmas Carol.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。今天我们从一个被称为守财奴的人的故事开始讲起。他是一个对他人困境无动于衷的人，以至于他成了贪婪和自私的代名词。他的名字叫埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇。斯克鲁奇先生，我想，确实是你，先生。当然，斯克鲁奇是查尔斯·狄更斯著名故事《圣诞颂歌》中的一个角色。
And yes, I know it's not Christmas, but stay with me a moment. In this 1984 film version of the story, Scrooge refuses to give money to a charity that's helping the poor. My taxes help to support the public institutions which I have mentioned, and they cost enough. Those who are badly off must go there. Many can't go there, and many would rather die.
是的，我知道现在不是圣诞节，但请听我讲下去。在这部1984年版的电影中，斯克鲁奇拒绝向帮助穷人的慈善机构捐款。我的税款已经用来支持我提到的那些公共机构了，它们已经花费够多了。那些穷困潦倒的人就该去那里。许多人去不了那里，许多人宁愿死。
If they would rather die, perhaps they'd better do so, and decrease the surplus population. Surely you don't need that. Scrooge is visited one night by some unwelcome guests who push him to question his outlook. Their ghosts. The first two remind him about his past and present and ask him to embrace the Christmas spirit.
如果他们宁愿死，也许他们最好还是去死，减少过剩的人口。你肯定不需要那样。一天晚上，斯克鲁奇被一些不速之客拜访，他们促使他审视自己的观点。他们是鬼魂。前两个鬼魂提醒他关于过去和现在的事情，并要求他拥抱圣诞精神。
It's to no avail. Scrooge cares more about his money than his community. But then he's visited by a third ghost who shows him his future. A grave. Terrified at the prospect of his own death, Scrooge begs the ghost to allow him to make a man's. He promises to become kind and generous, to care about his community, to embrace the Christmas spirit. Moments later, he wakes up. I'm a doctor.
这毫无用处。斯克鲁奇关心他的钱胜过关心他的社区。但随后，第三个鬼魂拜访了他，向他展示了他的未来。一座坟墓。面对自己死亡的前景，斯克鲁奇感到恐惧，他恳求鬼魂让他改过自新。他承诺会变得善良慷慨，关心社区，拥抱圣诞精神。片刻之后，他醒了过来。我是医生。
Thank you, Spirit. I will keep my promise. Here is why we are revisiting the story of Ebenezer's cruege. We tend to think of a Christmas Carol as a parable about the dangers of shutting our hearts to other people. But there's another lesson that comes from the story. It's a lesson about death. It was the fear of death that caused cruege to change his ways, and there is a great psychological truth in that story. Many of us shy away from consciously thinking about death, but it turns out death still figures
谢谢你，灵魂。我会信守承诺。这就是我们重温埃比尼泽·斯克鲁奇故事的原因。我们倾向于把《圣诞颂歌》看作是一个关于对他人关闭心扉所带来的危险的寓言。但这个故事还有另一个教训。这是一个关于死亡的教训。正是对死亡的恐惧促使斯克鲁奇改变了他的方式，这个故事中蕴含着一个伟大的心理学真理。我们许多人回避有意识地思考死亡，但事实证明，死亡在我们的脑海中出现的频率远比我们意识到的要高，而这些想法产生了一系列非凡的人类反应，从善良慷慨到怪异荒谬。本周《隐藏的大脑》将探讨关于死亡的想法如何塑造我们的生活。当谢尔顿·所罗门八岁时，他的母亲告诉了他关于死亡的事情。那是在我祖母因癌症去世的前一天。我记得我妈妈对我说，去和奶奶告别吧，因为她病得很重。我知道这一点，但第二天她就去世了。我记得当时我正在看我收集的已故总统的邮票。我就想，哇，华盛顿死了，杰斐逊死了，奶奶也死了，如果不是因为长远来看我也在名单上，那一切都还好。
in our minds far more often than most of us realize, and these thoughts produce an extraordinary range of human responses from the kind and generous to the strange and absurd. How thoughts of death shape our lives this week on Hidden Brain. When Sheldon Solomon was eight years old, his mother told him about death. This was the day before my grandmother died of cancer. And I remember my mom saying to me, oh say goodbye to grandma because she's very ill. And I knew that, but then she died the next day. And I just remember because I was looking at postage stamps that I collected at the time of dead presidents. And I was like, wow, Washington's dead, Jefferson's dead, grandma's dead, that would all be fine, except for me being on deck in the long run.
谢尔顿意识到有一天他的时间也会到来。几十年后，那个故事在他的生活中重新浮现。当时他是斯基德莫尔学院的一名年轻教授。他在图书馆找书时，弗洛伊德区的一本书引起了他的注意。那是一本由刚去世的文化人类学家欧内斯特·贝克尔写的书，书名叫《意义的诞生与死亡》。在第一段中，贝克尔说，
Sheldon realized that one day his time would also come. Decades later, that story re-emerged in his life. He was a young professor at Skidmore College. He was searching for a book in the library when something in the Freud section caught his eye. It was a book by a recently deceased cultural anthropologist, Ernest Becker, and that one was called the Birth and Death of Meaning. And in the first paragraph, Becker says,
我想了解是什么让人们做出那样的行为。我说，哦，我也是，终于有人不是用晦涩的术语写作了，这简直是治疗失眠的非药物干预，只是问了一个直截了当的问题，你知道是什么让人们做出那样的行为。谢尔顿在书架上看到了同一作者的更多书。于是我拿了下一本书，《拒绝死亡》，同样在第一段，贝克尔写道，死亡的概念。对它的恐惧像其他任何事物一样困扰着人类。它是人类活动的主要动力。
I want to understand what makes people act the way they do. And I said, oh me too, finally somebody not writing in Turgid jargon that's a non-pharmacological intervention for insomnia, just asking a straightforward question, you know what makes people act the way that they do. Sheldon saw more books on the shelf by the same author. So I grabbed the next book, The Denial of Death, and again the first paragraph backer writes the idea of death. The fear of it haunts the human animal like nothing else. It is a main spring of human activity.
这让我从内心深处回到了八岁的时候，我知道这个说法至少对我自己的生活是真实的，而且我怀疑这对大多数人来说也是真实的。谢尔顿联系了两位朋友，汤姆·皮辛斯基和杰夫·格林伯格。和像他一样，他们都是年轻的心理学家。他们三人都爱上了欧内斯特·贝克尔的书。吸引他们的核心思想是，人们构建心理防御机制来抵御对死亡的恐惧。这三位心理学家写了一篇论文，阐述了他们最终称之为“恐怖管理理论”的概念。他们把论文寄给了一家顶级期刊，
And in my gut that brought me way back to being eight years old, I knew that that statement was at the very least true for my own life, and I suspected that it was true for most folks as well. Sheldon reached out to two friends, Tom Pizinski and Jeff Greenberg. Like him, they were young psychologists. All three of them fell in love with Ernest Becker's books. The central idea that captivated them was that people construct mental defenses to ward off the fear of death. The three psychologists wrote up a paper elaborating on this concept they would eventually call this idea, Tera Management Theory. They sent off their paper to a top journal,
确信他们会震撼心理学界。我们大约六个月没有收到任何消息，然后我们收到了一份评审意见，论文被拒绝了，评审意见只有一句话。审稿人说，大意是，我毫不怀疑这些想法对任何活着或死去的心理学家都没有任何兴趣。所以这有点打击。好吧，杰夫和汤姆说，哦，我想他们不喜欢它。
certain they were going to rock the world of psychology. We didn't hear anything for about six months, and then we got a review, and the paper was rejected with a one sentence review. The reviewer said something along the lines of, I have no doubt that these ideas are of no interest whatsoever to any psychologist alive or dead. So this is a bit of a blow. Well, Jeff and Tom said, oh, I don't think they like it.
而我比他们更不成熟，我说，不，他们喜欢它。他们只是在装模作样。但事实证明他们并没有，因为同一篇论文随后在几乎所有的心理学期刊上都被拒绝了。后来，研究人员在一次会议上遇到了美国心理学会的主席，他们问他为什么论文被拒绝了。我们只是说，嘿，我们认为这些是好主意，他回答说，它们可能是，但心理学是一门实证学科。你们是实验心理学家。
And being even more immature than they, I said, no, they love it. They're just being coy. But it turns out they weren't because the same paper was then rejected at almost every psychology journal. Sometime later, the researchers ran into the president of the American Psychological Association at a conference and they asked him why the paper had been rejected. And we just said, hey, we think these are good ideas to which he replied, they might be, but psychology is an empirical discipline. You guys are experimental psychologists.
所以为什么不尝试收集证据来支持贝克尔的观点呢。正是为了回应这个建议，我们生成了我们所说的恐怖管理理论，这基本上只是我们努力将贝克尔的所有想法转化为我们可以进行实证检验的假设。所以，正如你刚才提到的，对贝克尔的批评之一是他的工作不是实证的。他提出的主张没有证据支持。他进行了涉及逻辑和哲学的直觉跳跃，但它们并非基于
And so why not try to gather evidence in support of Becker's claims. And it was in response to that suggestion that we generated what we call terror management theory, which is basically just our effort to take all of Becker's ideas and to generate hypotheses that we could subject to empirical scrutiny. So one of the criticisms of Becker, as you've alluded to a second ago, is that his work was not empirical. He was making claims that he didn't have evidence for. He was making these intuitive leaps involving logic and philosophy, but they weren't based
实证数据和实验。而你着手尝试解决这个问题。你的第一个实验涉及图森处理妓女案件的法官。告诉我这个研究以及它的发现。当然，当然。简而言之，恐怖管理理论指出，人类对死亡的独特意识会产生潜在的、令人衰弱的生存恐惧，我们通过拥抱文化构建的信仰体系来管理这种恐惧，因此得名“恐怖管理”，这些信仰体系让我们每个人都感觉到生活有
on empirical data and experimentation. And you set out to try and fix that. One of your first experiments involved judges in Tucson who were dealing with prostitutes. Tell me by the study and what it found. Sure, certainly. So, you know, in a nutshell, what terror management theory states is that the uniquely human awareness of death gives rise to potentially debilitating existential terror that we manage hence the term terror management by embracing culturally constructed belief systems that give us each a sense that life has
意义，我们有价值。正如你所说，人们在20世纪80年代所说的是，好吧，你知道，这是哲学和精神分析的推测。我们推断，如果贝克尔是对的，如果我们的现实信仰有助于最小化死亡焦虑，那么，让我们看看如果我们提醒一些人他们自己的死亡率会发生什么，因为应该发生的是他们应该更顽固地坚持他们的信仰。所以第一个研究是在亚利桑那州图森市的市政法院法官身上进行的。我想我们大约有30名法官，我们将他们随机分为两组。一半的法官在填写一堆问卷的过程中被提醒了他们的死亡率，
meaning and we have value. And as you said what would people said back in the days in the 1980s is well you know this is philosophical and psychoanalytic speculation. What we reasoned is that if Becker is right, if our beliefs about reality serve to minimize death anxiety, well, let's see what happens if we remind some people of their own mortality, because what should happen is they should cling more tenaciously to their beliefs. So the first study was done on municipal court judges in Tucson, Arizona. I think we had about 30 judges and we randomly divided them into two groups. Half of the judges were reminded of their mortality by in the middle of a bunch of questionnaires
被要求写下他们对自己死亡的想法和感受。然后我们向他们展示了一个涉嫌卖淫的真实法庭案件，这是当时图森市政法院最常见的犯罪。我们只是问他们，你会设定多少保释金？那是你为了在审判前不被监禁而必须支付的金额。所以我们发现，在对照组中，法官设定的平均保释金为50美元。这很好，因为那是当时该犯罪的平均保释金。然而，那些被提醒他们会死的法官，
being asked to just write down their thoughts and feelings about their own mortality. And then we showed them an actual court case of an alleged prostitute, which was the most common crime in Tucson's municipal court at the time. And we just asked them, well, how much bail would you set? That's the amount of money that you have to pay to not be imprisoned until your trial. So what we found is in the control condition, the judges set an average bail of $50. And that was good because that was the average bail for that crime at the time. However, the judges reminded that they were going to die.
他们设定的保释金高出九倍，平均为455美元。令人震惊的不仅是这种差异的幅度，还有法官抵制的激烈程度。当我们在研究结束时告诉他们我们做了什么时，他们只是说，你们那愚蠢的死亡问卷绝不可能以任何方式改变我审理这个特定案件的方式。所以我猜带回家的信息是，如果你因为交通罚单上法庭，你
They set a nine times higher bail, an average of $455. And what was astonishing is not only the magnitude of that difference, but also the vociferousness of the judge's resistance. When we told them at the end of the study what we had done, they just said there's no way that your idiot death questionnaire could have in any way altered the way that I have adjudicated this particular case. So I guess the take home message is if you're going to court for a traffic ticket, you
最好希望法官那天去法院的路上没有经过墓地。可能很难看出这与欧内斯特·贝克尔的想法有什么联系，所以让我们慢一点。恐怖管理理论的核心思想是，我们通过构建心理防御机制来应对对死亡的恐惧。谢尔顿和他的合著者发现，这些防御机制往往分为几种模式。当我们被提示思考死亡时，第一道主要的防御防线是退回到文化的避风港。
better hope that the judge hasn't driven past the cemetery on the way to court that day. It might be difficult to see how this is connected to Ernest Becker's ideas, so let's slow down a minute. The central idea of terror management theory is that we cope with the fear of death by constructing mental defenses. Those defenses, Sheldon and his co-authors found, tend to fall into a couple of patterns. The first main line of defense, when we are prompted to think about death, is to retreat into cultural safe havens.
我们的宗教、我们的社区、我们的价值观。这里的想法是，通过沉浸在我们文化群体的语言和规范中，我们成为了某种不那么会死的东西的一部分，即那些比我们活得更久的群体。当法官们被提醒他们的死亡率时，他们在某种程度上变得更加保守。他们试图惩罚那些打破了他们文化规范的女性。当然，这种行为可能有其他解释，所以谢尔顿和他的合著者决定进行一项新的实验。
Our religions, our communities, our values. The idea here is that by immersing ourselves in the language and norms of our cultural groups, we become part of something that is less mortal, the groups that will outlive us. When the judges were reminded of their mortality, they became in a way more conservative in their morality. They sought to punish women who had broken the norms of their culture. Of course, there could be other explanations for this behavior, so Sheldon and his co-authors decided to conduct a new experiment.
理由是，如果他们是对的，那么驱使法官严厉对待性工作者的同样力量也会产生另一种效果。当人们被提醒死亡时，他们也应该想要奖励那些体现社区规范的人。如果某人做了符合你信仰体系的事情，那么被提醒死亡应该会让你更喜欢他们。所以在随后的研究中，我们让参与者思考自己死亡或一些不愉快的事情，然后我们向他们展示了一篇关于一名挫败银行抢劫案的公民的报纸文章，
The reason that if they were right, the same forces driving judges to treat sex workers harshly would also produce another effect. When people are reminded of death, they should also want to reward those who exemplify the norms of the community. If somebody does something that's in accord with your belief system, then being reminded of death should make you like them more. So in a subsequent study, we had participants either think about themselves dying or something unpleasant, and then we showed them a newspaper article about a citizen who thwarted a bank robbery,
我们只是问他们，好吧，这位公民应该获得多少金钱奖励？在对照组中，大约是1000美元。而在死亡条件下，超过了3000美元。所以我也想谈谈其他几项研究，只是为了在这里铺开领域，有趣的是，这些研究已经在许多不同的国家进行了。你曾经问过德国人关于他们在食物、汽车和度假方面的偏好，一些人在零售环境中接受采访，另一些人在墓地前接受采访。你发现了什么？
and we just asked them, well, how much monetary reward should the citizen receive? In the control condition, it was about $1,000. And in the death condition, it was over $3,000. So I want to talk about a couple of other studies as well just to lay out the terrain here and what's interesting is that these studies have been conducted in many different countries. You once asked Germans about their preferences in food, cars and vacations and some were interviewed in a retail setting and others were interviewed in front of a cemetery. What did you find?
是的，这是一个很好的研究，原因有几个。我们没有做它，这让它更好，因为当其他研究人员能够复制你的发现时，这对科学目的总是很重要的。它还使用了一种非常巧妙的操作。所以我们提醒人们他们会死的一种方法是直接问他们对此有何感受。一种更微妙的方法是在殡仪馆前或两侧一百米处拦住人们。我们的想法是，如果你在殡仪馆前，那么死亡应该在你的脑海中，即使它隐藏在你的意识之外。果然，被提醒
Yes, this is a great study for a few reasons. We didn't do it and that makes it better because when other researchers can replicate your findings, that's always important for scientific purposes. It also used a very clever manipulation. And so one way that we remind people that they're going to die is to just ask them how they feel about it. A more subtle way is to stop people either in front of a funeral parlor, or a hundred meters to either side. And our thought was that if you're in front of a funeral parlor, well death should be on your mind even if it's hidden from your own awareness. And sure enough, Germans reminded
死亡率的德国人变得更支持购买德国商品。他们也坐得离其他德国人更近，离看起来像土耳其移民的其他人更远。所以，我认为会让人们感到惊讶的一件事不是死亡是可怕的这一论点，而是对死亡的恐惧在我们的生活中有着如此广泛的影响和后果的想法。我想知道你是否可以解决这个问题。在某些方面，这是对你理论的一种批评。说“是的，你知道，我们对死亡有担忧”是一回事，但你如何从那里得出结论说这实际上在我们的几乎所有想法、言语和行为中都起着深远的作用？是的，你知道，人们因为贝克尔说对死亡的焦虑本质上是激励我们作为人类行为的核心驱动力，而认为他
of their mortality, become more supportive of buying German goods. They also sit closer to fellow Germans and further away from other folks who look like Turkish immigrants. So, one of the things that I think would surprise people is not the thesis that death is terrifying, but the idea that the terror of death has such widespread ramifications and effects in our lives. And I'm wondering if you can just address this. In some ways, it is a form of criticism of your theory. It's one thing to say, yes, you know, we have concerns about death, but how do you go from there to saying that this actually has a profound role in almost everything that we think say and do? Yeah, you know, people dismissed Becker for being
宽泛到了夸张的地步。当你和人们谈论贝克尔的想法时，他们会说，这太疯狂了。我不会一直想死亡。贝克尔的观点是，你不会一直想死亡，因为你舒适地嵌入在你的文化世界观中，这种世界观通过你感觉自己是一个有价值的人，生活在一个有意义的世界中，从而缓冲了你的死亡焦虑。
broad to the point of grandiose when he said that anxiety about death is essentially the central driver of what it is that motivates us as human beings. When you talk to people about Becker's ideas, they'll be like, this is crazy. I don't think about death all the time. And Becker's view is that you don't think about death all the time because you're comfortably embedded in your cultural world view in a way that buffers you from death anxiety by virtue of the fact that you feel like you're a person of value in a world of meaning.
这里的想法是，即使对死亡的焦虑一直存在，我们也大多没有意识到它，因为我们的心理防御机制很强大。我们用我们的赞歌、仪式和我们认为我们的宗教是最好的信念来安慰自己。这些防御机制被突破的一种方式是当我们接触到与我们不同的人时，那些有自己信仰的人。现在，我们必须要么接受信仰只是信仰，要么我们必须试图证明我们的信仰更好。
The idea here is that even though the anxiety about death is ever present, we are largely oblivious to it because our mental defenses are strong. We soothe ourselves with our anthems and our rituals and our conviction that our religion is the best. One way these defenses are breached is when we come into contact with people different than us, people who have their own beliefs. Now, we must either accept that beliefs are just that, beliefs, or we must try to establish that our beliefs are better.
如果你的现实信仰有助于最小化死亡焦虑，那么当你遇到一个不同的人时，那就有问题了，因为如果我接受，比如说，马里的富拉尼人，他们说地球是由一滴巨大的牛奶创造的，那么这就削弱了上帝在六天内创造天地这一犹太-基督教叙述的真实性。因此，贝克尔说，当我们遇到不同的人时，我们倾向于贬低他们，我们倾向于试图说服或强迫他们放弃他们的想法，或者我们只是杀了他们，从而证明我们的上帝和我们的想法毕竟更好。
If your beliefs about reality serve to minimize death anxiety, well then when you run into somebody who's different, that's a problem because if I accept, let's say, the Fulane and Molly, who say the earth was created out of a giant drop of milk, well that undermines the veracity of the Judeo-Christian account that were God created heaven in earth in six days. What Becker said, therefore, is that when we encounter people who are different, we tend to belittle them, we tend to try to convince or coerce them to dispose of their ideas, or we just kill them, thus proving that our God and our ideas are better after all.
当我们回来时，我们将探讨这些想法如何在政治中发挥作用。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们已经看到了人们如何通过更紧密地依附于他们文化的各个方面来应对对死亡的恐惧。谢尔顿·所罗门和其他恐怖管理理论家也发现，人们对死亡的恐惧有第二种反应。他们找到了提升自己自尊的方法。除了说，我的文化是优越的，我的国家是最好的，我的宗教是最
When we come back, we explore how these ideas play out in politics. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. We've seen how people respond to the fear of death by clinging more tightly to aspects of their culture. Sheldon Solomon and other terror management theorists also find that people have a second kind of response to the fear of death. They find ways to boost their own self-esteem. Besides saying, my culture is superior, my nation is the best, my religion is the most
深刻的。他们还说，我是最好的，我比别人长得好看，我更聪明，我更有钱。我们称之为自尊追求。所以例如，我认为第一个研究是由以色列的奥里·托宾·贝纳里进行的。参与者是以色列士兵。他们测量了士兵的自尊在多大程度上基于他们的驾驶技术。
profound. They also say, I'm the best, I'm better looking than other people, I'm smarter, I'm richer. We call it self-esteem striving. And so for example, I think the first study was by Ori, Tobin Benari in Israel. And the participants were Israeli soldiers. And they measured the extent to which the soldier's self-esteem was based on their driving prowess.
我不知道你是否去过以色列，但他们非常疯狂。我怀着爱和尊重说这句话。然后他们把他们放在驾驶模拟器上。他们测量了士兵驾驶的速度和鲁莽程度。同样，好消息是在对照组中，士兵们驾驶得相当温和。但当他们首先被提醒他们的死亡率时，那些自尊基于驾驶技能的士兵。他们开得更快、更鲁莽。其他研究表明，被提醒死亡率的潜水员。他们说他们会待在水下
I don't know if you've been to Israel, but they are very maniacal. I say this with love and respect. And then they put them on a driving simulator. And they measured how fast and how recklessly the soldiers drove. And again, the good news is in the control condition, the soldiers drove quite modestly. But when they were reminded of their mortality first, the soldiers who self-esteem was based on their driving skills. They drove faster and more recklessly. Other studies have shown that skin divers reminded of their mortality. They say they would stay underwater
在更危险的天气里，或者当他们氧气快用完时。那些重视篮球技能的人，当他们被提醒死亡率时，他们在罚球线上实际上投得更好。那些认为自己强壮的人，如果你给他们东西挤压，当你提醒他们死亡率时，
in more dangerous weather or when they were running out of oxygen. People who value their basketball skill, when they're reminded of their mortality, they actually shoot better at the foul line. People that think they're strong, if you give them something to squeeze, when you remind them of their mortality,
他们实际上挤压得更用力。所以这些只是不同的证明，表明我们为了应对生存焦虑而支撑我们的自尊。关于涉及潜水员和以色列司机的研究，难道没有讽刺意味吗？提醒死亡率导致人们以增加他们死亡风险的方式行事。
they actually squeeze harder. So these are just different demonstrations that we shore up our self-esteem in response to existential anxieties. Isn't there something ironic about the studies involving the skin divers and the Israeli drivers where reminders of mortality cause people to act in ways about the studies involving the skin divers and the Israeli drivers, where reminders of mortality cause people to act in ways that increase their risk for
是的，那不是很深刻吗？我们曾经写过一本书的章节，死亡可能对你的健康有害，我们的观点很简单，因为我们心理上的主要目标是维持一种意义感和价值感，有时我们会这样做，即使是以牺牲我们的身体安全为代价。所以我们的学生杰米·戈登伯格和杰米·阿克所做的一项研究真的很了不起，他们表明，当佛罗里达州那些自尊依赖于外表的人，在一个晒黑被认为是美丽的世界里，好吧，当那些人被提醒死亡率几分钟后，当被问到，哦，下次你去海滩时，
mortality. Yes, is that not a poignant? We wrote at Book chapter once, death can be hazardous to your health, and our point was very simply that because our primary goal psychologically is to maintain a sense of meaning and value, there are times when we will do that even at the expense of our physical safety. So one of the studies that our students, Jamie Goldenberg and Jamie Arck did is really remarkable where they showed that when people in Florida whose self-esteem is dependent on their appearance in a world where being tan is considered beautiful, well, when those folks were reminded of their mortality a few minutes later when they were asked, oh, next time you go to the beach,
你会待在阳光下多久，你会使用什么样的防晒霜？好吧，那些人说他们会待得更久，使用更弱的防晒霜。所以他们在这里试图以一种最终可能导致他们死于癌症的方式来提升自尊。我想知道这些研究中的见解之一是否是我们真正试图避免的实际上不是死亡，而是对死亡的恐惧。而且很有趣且具有启发性的是，你将你的理论命名为恐怖管理理论，而不是死亡管理理论。
how long will you stay in the sun and what kind of sunscreen will you use? Well, those folks said they would stay out longer and use weaker sunscreen. So here they are trying to boost self-esteem in a way that could ultimately terminate them with cancer. I'm wondering if one of the insights in these studies is that what we're really trying to avoid is actually not death, but the fear of death. And it's interesting and instructive that you've named your theory terror management theory as opposed to death management theory.
这不是关于避免死亡，而是关于避免对死亡的恐惧。是的，我想你是对的。但公平地说，贝克尔在《拒绝死亡》的开头说，死亡实际上是一个复杂的、多维的结构。他声称人们害怕它。我们都害怕，但我们害怕它的原因可能不同。而且有很好的证据表明，对一些人来说，这真的不是死亡的前景。真正的恐怖是亲眼目睹我们处于那种转变过程本身的时刻。所以换句话说，是死亡的过程而不是死亡本身实际上是恐怖的来源。
It's not about avoiding death, it's about avoiding the fear of death. Yes, I think you're quite right. But in fairness to Becker, he says at the beginning of the denial of death that death is in fact a complex multi-dimensional construct. And people fear it, he claimed. We all do, but we may fear it for different reasons. And there is good evidence to suggest that, for some, it's really not the prospect of being dead. The real horror is to be privy to the moments when we're in the process of that transition itself. So in other words, it's the dying not the death that actually is a source of the terror.
是的，至少我认为对我来说是这样，尽管有时我想，我不知道，我真的，我想两者兼得。我不想死或正在死去，但我确实，我被伊壁鸠鲁派所吸引，他们说，好吧，你知道，在我们来到这里之前，人们已经在那里存在了亿万年，没有人担心过这一点，但我们几乎每个人都很难想象未来一个不包括我们的世界，为什么这会困扰我们？是的，我想当我真的死了，那不会困扰我太多。首先是让我感到恐惧。恐怖管理理论对我们被吸引的领导人有什么预测，
Yes, at least I think that's the case for me, although there are times when I think, I don't know, I really, I want to have it both ways. I don't want to be dead or be dying, but I do, I am compelled by the, I think it's the Epicureans who said, well, you know, there were people here for eons before we got here, and nobody's ever worried about that, but almost every one of us has a hard time imagining a world in the future that wouldn't include us, and why should that bother us? And yeah, I think when I'm really dead, that won't bother me so much. It's the get-me-er in the first place. What is Terra Management Theory predict about the kind of leaders that we are drawn to,
谢尔顿？是的，恐怖管理理论预测，当生存焦虑被唤起时，我们更有可能，当我说是我们时，我的意思是所有人都更有可能拥抱社会学家马克斯·韦伯所说的魅力型领导人。所以在9月11日之后，我们基于我们的研究认为，正是我们自己的生存焦虑吸引了美国人支持布什总统。这个国家与纽约市、泽西和康涅狄格州的善良人民站在一起。当我们哀悼失去，成千上万的公民。然后如果我们快进到2015年、2016年，唐纳德·特朗普宣布竞选总统，说，看，非法群体正越过南部边境。
shall they? Yes, term management theory predicts that when existential anxieties are aroused, that we are more likely, and when I say we, I mean all of us are more likely to embrace what the sociologist Max Weber called a charismatic leader. So in the aftermath of September 11th, we argued based on our studies that it was our own existential anxieties that attracted Americans to President Bush. This nation stands with the good people of New York City and the Jersey and Connecticut. As we mourn the loss, thousands of our citizens. And then if we fast forward to 2015, 2016, and Donald Trump declared his candidacy for the presidency saying, look, illegal swarms are coming over the southern border.
他们送来的人有很多问题，他们把这些问题带给我们。恐怖分子将进入美国，他们将杀死我们。他说，看，我是唯一能保证你们安全的人。我要让美国再次伟大。所以我们在2015年和16年做了研究。被提醒死亡的美国受访者更支持特朗普总统，现在的特朗普总统，并说他们更
They're sending people that have lots of problems, and they're bringing those problems with us. Terrorists are going to come into the United States, and they're going to kill us. And he said, look, I am the only one who can keep you safe. I'm going to make America great again. So we did studies in 2015 and 16. The American respondents reminded of death were more supportive of President Trump, now President Trump, and said they were more
可能在被提醒死亡率时投票给他。当唐纳德·特朗普显然要与希拉里·克林顿竞争时，我们发现受访者在心理平静的状态下更喜欢克林顿而不是特朗普，但如果他们首先被提醒死亡率，他们对特朗普总统的热情和支持就会大幅增加。而且，我们还做了其他研究，表明仅仅要求美国人思考在他们的社区建造一座清真寺或一个移民搬进他们的城镇，就足以让无意识的死亡想法更容易浮现在脑海中。
likely to vote for him when they were reminded of their mortality. When it became evident that Donald Trump was running against Hillary Clinton, we found the respondents preferred Clinton to Trump in a psychologically benign state of mind, but if they were reminded of their mortality first, their enthusiasm and support for President Trump was substantially increased. And then moreover, we did other studies where we showed that just asking an American to think about a mosque being built in their neighborhood or an immigrant moving into their town that that was sufficient to make unconscious death thoughts come more readily to mind.
而这反过来又增加了对现在的特朗普总统的支持。这很重要，因为特朗普总统的集会上没有死亡提醒。所以人们可能会想，好吧，这有什么实际意义？事实是，他不需要。仅仅保持移民和恐怖主义，以及中国人和其他每个国家在很大程度上由于其激进的贸易行为而对我们构成致命威胁的想法。所有这些，无论总统是否意识到，都有助于维持高水平的死亡焦虑，而这反过来又有助于维持对魅力型
And that in turn increased support for now President Trump. This is important because President Trump doesn't have death reminders in his rallies. And so one might wonder, well, how is this of practical significance? Well, the fact is that he doesn't have to. Just keeping immigration and terrorism and the idea that the Chinese and every other country for the most part are a mortal threat to us by virtue of their aggressive trade practices. All of that, whether the president is aware of it or not, serves to maintain a high level of death anxiety, and that in turn serves to maintain greater support for a charismatic
领导人的更大支持。这似乎在当前的政治时刻反映了我们谈论的一些主题。例如，当我想到党派之争时，我想到那些想要坚持那个部落的人，因为部落长期以来提供了抵御死亡和其他威胁的保护。绝对。我们从根本上是部落动物，无论好坏，令人担忧且可能灾难性的，不是为了听起来太戏剧化，但我们正处于一个我们作为美国人已经失去了压倒性的共同点的地步。这确实冒着我们的党派身份，如果推到谚语般的推搡，优先于什么对我们最好
leader. This seems to be so much in the current political moment that reflects some of the themes that we've talked about. When I think about partisanship, for example, I think of people who want to stick to that tribe because the tribe has long offered protection against death and other threats. Absolutely. We are fundamentally tribal animals for better and worse and what's problematic and potentially catastrophic not to sound too histrionic, but we're at a point where we have lost overriding commonality as Americans. And this does run the risk of our partisan identities if push comes to proverbial shove, taking precedent over what's best
作为这个国家的公民本身的风险。你做了一些研究，观察自由派和保守派在涉及辣酱的实验中如何对待彼此。告诉我那个研究。所以我们有自由派和保守派参与者，他们认为他们正在与一个自由派或保守派伙伴合作，然后他们得知他们的伙伴不喜欢辛辣食物。他们被告知，好吧，好的，你要吃一些饼干并评价你有多喜欢它们，你的伙伴要吃一些辣酱。你可以决定他们必须吃多少辣酱，他们必须
for us as citizens of the country itself. You've done some work looking at how liberals and conservatives behave toward one another in an experiment that involves hot sauce. Tell me about that study. So we had liberal and conservative participants who thought they were working with a liberal or conservative partner, and then they learned that their partner didn't like spicy foods. And they were told, well, okay, you're going to eat some crackers and rate how you like them and your partner is going to eat some hot sauce. And you get to determine how much hot sauce they're going to have to eat and they have
吃掉所有，然后评价它有多令人愉快。好吧，在对照组中，你合作的人是否分享你的信仰并不重要，你给他们的辣酱量是一样的。另一方面，如果你首先被提醒死亡，如果伙伴分享你的政治观点，你给他们的酱汁量是一样的，但如果他们不分享，你给他们的量是两倍。我们通过事后与参与者交谈证实这是一种攻击性反应。他们不知道这与被提醒死亡率有关，但当我们说，你知道你基本上是在给这些人下药，因为他们不喜欢辣酱吗？他们说，你做得对，我们是。
to eat all of it and then rate how pleasant it was. All right, so in the control condition, it didn't matter whether the person you were working with shared your beliefs or not, you gave them the same amount of hot sauce. On the other hand, if you were reminded of dying first, you gave the same amount of sauce to the partner if they shared your politics, but if they didn't, you gave them twice as much. And we confirmed that this was an aggressive reaction by talking to the participants afterwards. They didn't know that it had anything to do with being reminded of their mortality, but when we said, did you know that you were essentially dosing these folks because they didn't like hot sauce? They're like, you're done right, we are.
我想知道你个人是什么感觉，谢尔顿，花了这么多职业生涯思考像死亡这样令人愉快的话题。它改变了你自己对死亡率的看法吗？是的，我愿意这样想，但我不能确定。我们，意思是杰夫、汤姆和我开玩笑说，但相当认真地说，恐怖管理理论使我们免于直接面对我们自己的生存焦虑，因为通过把它变成一种智力练习，它确实让我们保持了一点距离。
I'm wondering what it's like for you personally, Sheldon, to have spent so much of your career thinking about a cheery topic like death. Has it changed the way you thought about mortality yourself? Yeah, I would like to think so, but I can't say for sure. Weed meaning Jeff and Tom and I have joked, but quite seriously, that terror management theory has spared us the necessity of directly confronting our own existential anxieties, because by turning it into an intellectual exercise, it really does distance us a bit.
我愿意认为我正在进步，当我时不时问自己时，我在自己的自我反思中更准确一点，好吧，你为什么要做这些事情？这只是为了让自己感觉更好以管理焦虑，还是这更真实地代表了我愿意为了它们本身而采取的方向？所以我希望我正在取得进步。谢尔顿·所罗门是斯基德莫尔学院的心理学教授。他与杰夫·格林伯格和汤姆·皮辛斯基一起，是《核心的温暖：死亡在生活中的作用》的合著者。谢尔顿，感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。
And I'd like to think that I'm coming along and that I'm a little bit more accurate in my own self-reflections when I ask myself from time to time, well, why are you doing things? Is it just to feel better about yourself in order to manage anxiety or is this something that more genuinely represents directions that I would like to take for their own sake? So I hope I'm making progress. Sheldon Solomon is a psychology professor at Skidmore College. Along with Jeff Greenberg and Tom Pizinski, he's the co-author of The Warm at the Core on the role of death in life. Sheldon, thank you for joining me on Hidden Brain today.
非常感谢，这太棒了。本周的节目由雷娜·科恩制作，塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队包括帕特·沙阿、劳拉·科雷尔和托马斯·刘。我们本周的无名英雄是听众苏·戈尔斯基。苏是一名初中科学老师。今年夏天，她想通过手工清洁每一块石头来重振她房子周围的岩石花园床。这是一个耗时且孤独的任务。
Thank you so much, it was great. This week's show was produced by Raina Cohen, edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Pat Shah, Laura Correll and Thomas Liu. Our unsung hero this week is listener Sue Gorski. Sue is a middle school science teacher. This summer she wanted to revitalize the rock garden beds around her house by cleaning each stone by hand. It was a time consuming and solitary task.
所以苏让《隐藏的大脑》成为了她的伴侣。在一封电子邮件中她写道，第一天我开始听《隐藏的大脑》第1集。还有待观察的是，我会先用完播客还是先用完石头。能和你一起度过夏天真是太高兴了。谢谢你让我们成为你夏天的一部分，苏。像你这样的笔记一直是一个巨大的鼓励来源。如果你有一个朋友正处于漫长的岩石花园项目或任何其他需要陪伴的项目中，请选择你最喜欢的《隐藏
So Sue made Hidden Brain her companion. In an email she wrote, on my first day I started listening to Hidden Brain episode 1. What remains to be seen is if I will run out of podcasts or rocks first. What a joy to be able to spend the summer with you. Thanks for letting us be a part of your summer soon. Notes like yours have always been a big source of encouragement. If you have a friend in the midst of a long rock garden project or any other kind of project that calls for companionship, please choose your favorite episode of Hidden
的大脑》剧集并与他们分享。我们真的很感激。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Brain and share it with them. We really appreciate it. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
分享给他们。我们非常感谢。我是Shankar Vedantum，这是NPR。这是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。